two-time corporate chess league champion
edward jones has already punched its
ticket to the final four
in december for every other team tonight
is their last shot welcome to the final
stop of the regular season
of the 2020 corporate chess league
good evening and welcome to the final
gathering
of the regular season for the 2020
corporate chess league
four teams will continue on from here to
compete
for the final 2020 corporate chess
league championship
seven teams unfortunately will be sent
home
to look forward to next year we look to
enhance and expand what we're doing with
the corporate chess league
going on into 2021 so we really
appreciate your participation
if you have other colleagues or those in
your network
that are interested in competing if
you've enjoyed
this please pass along this information
to them we're getting interest
from other states outside of st louis
boston area
new york area and so we have a lot of
ideas
moving forward into 2021 i want to say a
special thank you
to those in the st louis chess club
of course we could not put on this
corporate chess league
without them without our hosts without
those that have organized
everything for us and so transitioning
onto this virtual platform
this year has certainly been a challenge
and that challenge has been met very
well so thank you all for participating
and being engaged we've had 11 teams
50 plus players from across the greater
st louis area
wanting to participate in this league so
we look forward to next year
thank you for being here and good luck
to those who are continuing
on after today and now let's turn it
over to our host
national master caleb dimby caleb
take it away and thank you to alex for
the lovely intro it's often been said
that chess is a give
a is a game of give or t give and take
and tonight we're going to see which one
of these corporations
can negotiate their way through the
complications
the players are still getting ready to
be paired up and get started here so
let's talk a little bit about the format
of tonight
of course this is the final leg of the
corporate chess league
grand prix and as alex said the top four
teams after tonight are going to qualify
for the finals
next month in december so why don't we
just see where all those teams stand
right now
uh i think edward jones is far and away
clearing first place as the intro said
they have
300.5 points uh almost
double that of second place so they will
be continuing to the finals
but then merits worldwide technology
enterprise bayer and ascension any of
them could qualify
and likewise none of them are safe so
they're going to have to have a good
night here
tonight in order to secure their spot in
those december finals
and speaking of the grand prix why don't
we take a look at the format and how
those points are actually scored
so tonight we're gonna have two rounds
one starts at 6
15 p.m and each round actually consists
of two games so the players will play
two games with their opponent one with
the white pieces
and one with the black pieces and each
round
is worth 20 grand pre-points and those
go
to the winner of the team match so these
corporations
each corporation's team is paired up
with one other corporation
and the winner of the match the team who
scores the majority of the points
gets 20 extra grand prix points
but on top of that your board score is
also added to your grand prix point
total
what does that mean well that means that
every single point scored in the match
whether it be whether it be for the
winning team or the losing team is added
to that grand prix total
so players with or teams with more
players
definitely have a little bit of an edge
because even if they lose the match they
can still put up some points
on those lower boards uh with that in
mind
let's uh talk a little bit about the
pairings in this first round
so edward jones uh like i said far and
away the leaders
but they are actually paired up against
enterprise who find themselves
just barely qualifying after the first
few
legs of the the grand prix so they will
need to do well against edward jones to
defend their fourth place spot
or else they may be relegated they may
lose their
fourth place qualifying spot and have to
go home and try
harder next year we also have merits
against bayer now merits is in second
place right now and they do have a
little bit of a cushion
between them and the fourth place spot
but i am willing to say that they are
not
safe if they have a bad night here
tonight if they don't win either of
their matches i think they are very much
in danger of not qualifying bayer by the
way
is one of those teams that i believe is
on the cusp of qualifying and will need
to do well
to knock out one of those top four teams
we also have
worldwide technology against ascension
and
both of those teams are also very much
in the running for qualifying i think
worldwide technology
holds third place but ascension is i
think within
15 or 20 points so as always one win in
that match and ascension
yeah only 16 points behind worldwide
technology if they win here tonight
uh i believe they will overtake their
competitors
so a lot up for grabs doherty of course
i believe
has the buy in the first round but all
of their players will still
be playing uh matches uh whenever there
is a bit of a mismatch in the rosters
whenever a team has
an extra player or two they move to an
extra
match zone and do still get to play all
of their games
regardless so it's gonna be a lot of fun
to see what's going on
and i'm receiving word that the matches
are starting
so why don't we take a look i want to
start with this game between
dv dutch board one for world wide
technology
against kyqz board one for ascension and
this is
a rather big matchup although not as big
as those numbers would say
uh dv dutch apparently i do know who
this is
i think he's around a 1 500 1600 rated
player
i don't know why his chest.com rating is
890 but trust me that's not
accurate so this is definitely one to
look out for and it looks like we
actually have an exchange slav i just
want to flip through these opening moves
really quickly
we see white taking on d5 and this sort
of has a reputation for being a bit
boring because
all the pieces start to look the same
for both sides it's very symmetrical
but we are going to see a little bit of
a difference in this game and that
happens
because of black's fifth move here e6
because of this move i'm inclined to
think white actually has a little bit of
advantage
why is that well this bishop is going to
be a little bit stuck
behind its own pawns here it would love
to be on a square like f5 or g4
where it can be active and participate
in the game
but we'll see that black may actually
have some problems getting this bishop
into the game
we do see h6 and bishop takes f6 so an
interesting trade of the bishop for the
knight
and i do think this is in black's favor
but it will
uh what we'll have to see if black
really understands why
the reason why this is good for black is
because black can start to solve the
problem of this bishop by pushing this
pawn to e5
and it very much does look like black
knows
what he's doing here because rookie 8
seems to be preparing this e5 push as
black should play
you have to solve this bishop get this
bishop into the game
to be okay uh yeah bishop d7 i don't
think it's an awful move but
i i don't think it's going with the plan
plan was e5
now it's going to be a little bit harder
because the bishop is actually in the
way of the queen's defense of the pawn
here so
dv dutch still outraged by a few hundred
points but i'm liking his position
we'll have to keep an eye on this game
for sure
let me pull up board number two here
we've got sweet man
on board 2 for worldwide technology
and sweet man is pairing off against
frank tan
a little bit of rhyming there and
sweet man and frank tan these two
players are a little bit closer on the
rating scale now it's worth noting that
ascension has a little bit
bit of an edge at those top two boards
their top two players are a bit higher
rated than worldwide technologies
but they kind of make up for that uh
does worldwide technology on the lower
boards
they are the favorites on the bottom
three boards ascension
the favorites on the top two and what is
this chest position
oh my god uh what
on earth is going on here we see two
bishops versus two knights a very ugly
structure on the king's side for black
you want to keep these pawns more
together in line so they can move up and
protect each other
right now these three pawns will never
be able to defend each other
ever again for the rest of the game and
what's worse for black is that this
bishop is going to be
very very difficult to actually activate
you're going to have to get it outside
these pawns as in that first game that
we talked about
and it's even more difficult here maybe
black can go something like c5
and try to activate the bishop this way
on this
long diagonal if i could draw the arrow
there it is
maybe black will play a5 and try to get
it out through a6
it's going to be a difficult challenge
though now we actually see black play an
interesting move f5
and an interesting series of trades here
so
black trades off his seemingly good
bishop but in return
he actually helped his structure on the
king's side a little bit things are not
quite as bad over
here and the path to activating this
bishop
is maybe becoming a bit clearer frank
though
not one to give up easily is putting
some pressure on the d
file and this again is going to make it
difficult to get this bishop in the game
it's a very similar story on these top
two boards it's a story
of trying to activate this light squared
bishop with the black pieces
uh let's take a look though at that
third board as well
we have wades for worldwide technology
up against s gilmore 999
for ascension and in this one
thankfully it's a different story this
bishop can breathe a little bit it's not
going to have such a difficult time
of coming into the game and a very
interesting move here
by white is knight d5 back to c3 i would
assume that's where the knight came from
so white wasting a little bit of time in
the opening jumping out
to d5 but then directly retreating not
sure how i feel about that one you don't
really want to waste that much time in
an opening like this
that being said this position isn't bad
for s gilmore
at all and here again i do want to
mention these players chess.com ratings
they're not always accurate
weights is listed as a 1500 on our
pairing sheet
and whereas s gilmore only a 14.60 so
despite the 1200 rating look to weigh
look for wades
to try and actually score a few points
for his team here
and okay we see d5 from white and knight
b8 from black so probably at first
glance this move knight b8 looks very
bad for black right
you don't really want to waste time in
the opening like i've been saying
but here i don't actually mind it
because this knight
is rerouting to d7 and then it's going
to look at these two squares
that white stopped attacking by
overextending
this pawn so despite d5 gaining some
time
it does give up some really crucial
squares on c5 and e5 and we'll see if
black
is able to take advantage i really am
not the biggest fan of black's last move
however because it weakens this d-pawn
forever
you want to be a little bit cautious
whenever pushing these pawns forward
it's going to give you some weaknesses
like i said at the top of the hour
or at least tried to say a chess is a
game
of give and take so e6
is taking some control of the d5 square
and activating along the e file but it's
giving white a target here on d6
so it's a question of who's getting the
better deal
by the way white rum uh still has his
king left in the center
going to have to spend some time to fix
this piece
and i'm willing to bet black's next move
is going to be rook to e8
with some awkwardness here definitely
along the e file
looks good for black in my opinion looks
good for black
let's keep on moving down the list we
have sfx
77 on the next board for
uh worldwide technology and i actually
don't see that game i just don't see it
there it is it apparently is only going
to show me five games at a time so i
will have to budget
the games that i follow and here we have
sfx with black again
and once again not a super accurate
rating here sfx not a 1200
much closer to 1400 and
what is this position my gosh they're
getting some some crazy stuff it looks
like
you know many of these worldwide
technology players are doing something
similar
with the black pieces here um going for
the
this d6 e5 setup playing on the dark
squares
with the fiance bishop i wonder if
they've done some team prep
going into this match
and as we join this game it does look
like
white is meeting being faced with some
awkwardness on the c file here with
black
bearing down on both of those pieces
bishop takes a6 i think was
forced taking a piece to gain some time
to save the night
and i don't think white is losing but is
white better
is white better here well
i've just counted the pieces and i don't
think white is better
why is that white has fewer pieces it's
sometimes worth it to count black is
sitting with an extra knight here on
h5 that being said i'm not in love with
what sfx just did
that does give up this b7 pawn and as
the pawns start to trickle
in look for oak avenue to try and turn
this game around
you can only give up so many pawns
before it's worth a piece and white
is up to three that's right three pawns
for the piece
it's definitely not nothing and white is
very much still in this game
that just leaves whedon on board five
for worldwide technology and then i
think we're gonna stick with this match
for the rest of round one here
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that game we have whedon 80
on uh with the white pieces here against
peppermint peppermint with the black
pieces
is ascension's board five uh and so like
i said board one board two
look for kyqz and frank tan for
ascension to look to score some points
they are the favorites there pretty
heavily so
but then on these three lower boards
that's where worldwide technology will
need
to make a stand they need to score the
points
they uh are favored to score here
and looking at this position it looks
like we've simplified it quite a bit
here
whedon has the bishop against pet
peppermints knights
and black again we're seeing a lot of
this d6e5 structure
that usually results from you know a
sicilian defense
and as always this d6 pawn is looking to
be
a slight weakness in the position for
black
that being said it's always worthwhile
to count the pawns one two three four
one two three four five d6 is actually
an
extra pawn for black which means black
is just for choice here this is not one
of those positions
where white is getting compensation for
the pawn black has an
excellent square for the knight this
extra pawn is useful supporting the
center
and controlling some squares in the c
file black should just simplify
bring this rook over to c8 and there's
absolutely no reason why
black shouldn't be able to win this game
so good news
for ascension on this lower board here
if they can
score a point or two on these lower
boards they are in very good position
to take home the match with good results
on board one
and boards one and two that being said
though a6 not the most accurate
black needed to contest this c file now
the rook will invade on the seventh rank
and uh
white will look to to take some material
although the more i look at it was this
is
was this a sneaky trap did peppermint
lay a very devious trap here it seems as
though
that may have been the case i think
actually believe it or not
king d8 in this position and black would
have been picking up a piece
through some very very strange tactics
um
rook d7 check is the only move because
after king d8
both of these pieces are attacked so
king d8 rook d7
king e8 is the stunning move that i just
was not seeing
and once again black is in contact with
the rook and in contact with the bishop
if the rook moves anywhere with check
then we can capture the bishop for free
the bishop moves back then b5 and it's
the same problem for white
king d8 would have won the game with a
stunning tactic
but it was missed in this case apologies
if you guys didn't follow that all the
way through
but yeah weed is now looking to do the
same thing but it's it's the same exact
tactic
it's the same problem king g6 here and
both of white's pieces
are attacked perhaps though white in
this case can save the day
with a move like bishop a2 would have
been an insane tactic to see here from
pet peppermint that
was a wild one oh b3 but this isn't good
enough
rook takes pawn takes king takes and
black is going to be up a piece here
looking very good for pep peppermint
that'll be a massive upset for ascension
on this board
five uh so let's keep an eye though
on this board one match up as well we
have dv dutch against kyqz
and things have changed in the worst of
ways for dv dutch here i think
uh kyqz has managed to
escape his slightly awkward position and
let's just take a look at how he did
that really quickly
i mentioned bishop d7 wasn't my favorite
move but then look at this
knight a4 and black immediately punishes
this move with e5
as i said this is the key break for
black here to activate this bishop
and as always chess a game of give and
take as i said
knight a4 is claiming the c5 and
b6 squares but it's giving up the d5
square
you have to give something to get
something and in this case e5 is
playable because of that
now with the active bishop in more space
in the center no reason
why black should be unhappy and we see
in the game
after some simplifications we ended up
right here and the rooks have now been
traded
and it is definitely uh black for
choice why is black for choice well this
one pawn
is worth a lot more than this f2 pawn
double pawns aren't ideal in the end
game
and in this case dv dutch is to have to
work a bit hard
to in fact play i think for a draw here
if i'm black
i'm definitely going to take on h4 here
you want to create two different past
pawns
will it be enough to win honestly
probably
not i think white has a pretty solid
setup here
actually thanks to these f pawns i
wouldn't even think about moving those
things
so why is it a draw well because these
bishops are on opposite colors
they're sort of playing two different
chess games right this bishop is playing
a chess game
on the light squares on the board it can
only access these squares
meanwhile black is playing a chess game
on the dark squares
of the chessboard right only able to
access those
as well so because these bishops can
never really interact with each other
oftentimes these end games turn out to
be a draw
however i think q y k
k k y q z it's going to be a tough one
for me tonight
with these names i think he's doing a
good job of actually putting on a little
bit of pressure here
there is now a slight narrow path for
this king to potentially invade
let's say somehow miraculously this
bishop was on
f6 and this king was on d6 then maybe
black could try to win
with an invasion here but i don't really
see that happening
looking to be a draw back on board two
we have a slightly different story here
we have black with just an
extra bishop and this is
sweet man with the extra bishop is that
right and going forward
to promote okay looking bad for frank
tan here the bishop
is a lot better than a knight at
stopping past pawns and in this case
these pawns are for the moment frozen
where they stand
no way sweet man is letting these guys
promote and i think with good play here
sweetman should come out on top
should come out on top how is he going
to come out on top well i think he
actually
should be bringing his king uh closer to
his pawn
then maybe you can give a check bring
the king in
push the pawn come back to stop the
enemy pawns
and put white into zugsvang i know that
that wasn't
the most coherent and oof i do not like
this move
do not like this move by sweet man this
is trying to give away the victory here
it's true now that white is in stalemate
with the king
but has to move one of the pawns at
first glance
that seems very very good for black
right you want white to move upon so you
can take it
but look at this whenever black takes
this pawn king f7 and there's just no
way to defend the f6 pawn
and frank tan has snatched a draw from
the jaws of victory there you go
um yeah no way sweet man should lose
this of course you can always just
sacrifice the bishop for the pawn or win
the pawn outright
but it won't be more than a draw for
sweet man with the extra bishop
and that's two draws on the top two
boards which i think
is actually going to be good news for
worldwide technology
as i said those top two boards are where
worldwide technology
needs to hold their ground need to stand
their ground against ascension
because ascension is the favorite on
those two boards
if you're bored one and two for wwt
you're looking at your lower boards to
do the heavy lifting here to score those
points for you while you sort of take it
easy and try and put up
a decent score against your opponents as
well
with that in mind let me just take a
quick look at some results we've got
here
and there are no results here ah
probably because
nick is playing nick the lovely uh
tournament director of this event
updates those scores for me live but
he's also playing so why don't we take a
look at him
see how nick is doing chess worm is his
name
and i have to get rid of a game so i can
see that one
okay i have to get rid of more games and
yeah chessworm is is battling it out
here against
mick nick jim jm close enough
looks to be good for nick though this
pawn is going to be really strong
it's a protected past pawn which means
it's always threatening the queen
and it's always going to be protected by
another pawn and now
nick just making an inroad for his king
is going to be able to to win this game
all right let's stick though with this
board one
of worldwide technology against
ascension for a bit longer here
uh and let's look from from kyqz's point
of view we've been
looking from the other view for some
time now i don't want to
play favorites here i was only looking
from worldwide technology's
side because those are the player names
that i typed in
but kyqz needs to put up a point here
needs to do it for his team
uh as i said ascension needs these top
two boards to come in strong
so what's going on in this chess game it
looks like a very
imbalanced game uh a bit of a bit of a
difference
than the game one we saw between these
two players in the exchange slot
uh here black is gonna have a very
active bishop on this long
dark squared diagonal but white is gonna
enjoy
the bishop pair advantage and a little
bit of extra central space
notably white has sacrificed a pawn to
get this position
so if black can sort of consolidate
activate the pieces
trade off some of white's active pieces
then black should be for choice
kyqc though definitely not going to let
that happen easily
d5 by black is an attempt to get rid of
that annoying e pawn and
as i said activate and start initiating
some trades that is what is on dv
dutch's mind here
now what do i do if i'm ky qz
in this position well i don't mind this
trade at all actually
it draws this e pawn out to the d5
square where it's going to be a little
bit
weak right it's isolated no pawns on the
neighboring files to help it out
so kyqz can just start activating the
rooks now
bring pieces to the center and sort of
let the bishops
do the work for him here the bishops are
just always going to be strong in a wide
open position
like this is it enough for the extra
pawn
it remains to be seen but white does
have some compensation here
with those bishops with some pressure on
the d-pawn
it's going to be a a close fight here
understandably kyq z taking some time
but i
i really do think it's time to get this
rook off of this long diagonal that just
makes me nervous
i don't like it when my rooks are in the
same diagonal as bishops
i get very terrified so for my heart
kyqz i implore you
please move your rook away from that
bishop
um okay bishop e3
yeah not one to to help my
uh you know heart stress i guess
um and bishop e3 is putting the knight
in sort of a pin to counteract the
pressure on this diagonal and now we do
see rook c1
finally thank goodness i can sleep easy
and yeah with black i think now the key
is to make sure this pawn is relevant
with white
the key is to make sure this pawn is
weak so look for dv dutch to do
something like knight c6
try and push this pawn even further up
the board
and yeah i really don't like this move
b5
by dv dutch this pawn
was actually i think better placed on b7
this is a mistake i see a lot of amateur
players make sometimes at the club level
they see their opponent as gaining some
space on the queen side with
a3 b4 and they sort of just want to
follow suit with a6 b5
but if you actually look at the squares
getting controlled
the c6 square is a lot more important
than the c4 and a4 squares
black already controls this square and
c6 would have been a nice square
for this knight to be able to retreat to
so b5 i think is a step in the wrong
direction bishop b1 by white
and yeah now we see another big
downside to playing b5 you can no longer
ever play b6 to evict this rook
from the active c5 outpost i think now
it is
white for choice here i would much
rather have this active rook
have this active bishop than then have
this d-pawn i think
okay rookie one gets played and it again
is now just a test of if black can sort
of fix the position
right black was so so close to
consolidating and then took a couple
steps in the wrong direction kyqz
keeping up the pressure
with activating this rook and bringing
the other rook into the game
and can dv dutch navigate uh his way
through these complications for example
knight f5 is striking my mind already
i'm willing to give up
this pawn on d5 just to activate my
pieces
tv dutch holding on a bit stronger
though wants to double up on the d
file and hold on to this pawn for dear
life
why don't we leave those two players to
it chessworm
did win that game and why don't we check
back in here on sweet man versus frank
tan
we do have sweet man with the white
pieces and it's another really
interesting position a lot of pieces
left on the board we have black castling
queenside and white castling king's side
and interestingly black has castled on a
side of the board where he has
also pushed a lot of his pawns forward
now usually that's not a good idea but i
think
it is the right plan in this case
why is that well the position is fairly
closed
meaning these pawns are going to stay on
the board for a while you're not going
to see any open diagonals any open files
over here
and since the position is so closed it
is better just to have this extra space
it's not going to do any harm
to castle over here with that in mind
though i i
can't say i like this last move by by
frank i think b4
would have been good for black would
have maintained some advantage here
uh with the idea of just keeping this
extra space and keeping a few more files
closed after ba4 this open diagonal is
going to be very relevant
as well as this open a file it's looking
like it's going to get a little bit
dangerous on the queen side for black
here looks like bishop d2
followed by b3 and opening up the b file
as well all of these ideas
are sort of spring to mind now for white
what do we see in the game the bishop
actually dropped back to c2
and a strange queen h3 just to apply
some pressure to this e6 pawn
black defends laterally with the queen
and
yeah a lot of chests left to be played
here which side
do i prefer
how come that 890 keeps everything
together well as i said before manny he
is not actually 890. i think he's around
1600
uscf and i think he just doesn't play on
chess.com
so that 890 rating a little bit
misleading
dv dutch is around 1600 i believe
okay we see rook d1 in an interesting
choice by black to go
e4 locking down the center entirely
and in general i think this is a good
principled way
to approach the position why is that
well
this bishop was thriving on c2 it loves
open diagonals bishops love
open diagonals and with e4 you're not
only shutting down
this bishop but you're keeping this pawn
on e3 which is shutting down this bishop
as well now white is going to have a
very difficult time
making use of these bishops whereas the
knights can do
some hippity hopping and apply some
pressure
on the king's side of the board that
knight goes there
this knight for example goes here and
black is going to have a ton of pressure
in the position
i think black is definitely for choice
at this point
some good positional ideas here by
frank tan playing against the bishops
you don't often see it
but it does work on occasion
and what's this dv dutch has fallen
to kyqz it turns out that activity
was just a bit too much and we actually
saw the blunder of a queen
wow we had just left this game with
knight f5
uh but then bishop f4 and the pieces
start getting pushed around
i think perhaps this was an idea in the
position as well
not sure how black would have responded
with this threat
but rook c7 instead and then after d4
this queen was attacked and subsequently
hung
not good for dv dutch but he did
get that half point in the first round
which is a lot
better than uh than nothing
if sweet man can perhaps score another
half point here or even a full point
then worldwide technology would be in
great position
however if frank tan does manage to to
clean this game up
i think ascension may even be a little
bit favored right they scored
three out of four on the top two boards
there which is
not bad at all assuming frank would be
able to win this game
with that in mind frank is not
necessarily going to win this game
i liked his position a moment ago but
then things did start to open up we saw
strange looking king
c7 here i think probably i liked better
getting these knights into these good
light squared outposts and then after b3
we do see the position start to collapse
now for black
i wonder if queen takes c6 was missed
it's
been responded to with queen take c3
and this is what's known sometimes as a
desperado tactic
so black is willing to give up this
knight in exchange for the bishop
on c2 instead of bishop a4
and yeah this is what i cautioned
against i said black could
castle king's side and it's uh it should
be fine as long as the files stay
closed and now white has successfully
opened the files with some help from
black
and this king is going to find itself in
a world of hurts
it's difficult to even suggest moves
here for black
the very very simple plan of bishop d2
rook c1
and checkmate is going to be a difficult
one to stop here for frank tan
we see knight c6 but again this move
bishop d2
comes to mind and i think that would end
the game just some tactics
bishop d2 queen c4 we can take on c6
take on c6 and rook c1 pinning the queen
to the king
sweet man starts with bishop d2 will he
find the rest will he find the rest here
to win the game
queen c4 bishop takes c6 wins i don't
think rook c1 is good enough just yet
it gives up the bishop on a4 but this is
winning and yeah
sweet man has found it rook c1 and that
is going to be the match i don't see
frank recovering from this one
queen to c6 check bishop takes a5 as
well
queen takes d5 just as good this one is
going
to be a victory for sweet uh
sweet man sweet man and frank tan what
what a group of names
um yeah i think check might be the
simplest with
check and check and mate
to follow
also rook a6 series rook c6 to a6 is
maybe the meanest way to deliver
checkmate here
but just queen takes a five is good
enough yeah once again
queen b5 king va file rook a1
is checkmate this is checkmate as well
and sweetman does take it home
all right let us take a look now at
those lower boards
once again back to whedon versus pi
peppermint
disaster how did peppermint lose that
first game
the i thought it was in the bag for pep
peppermint uh whedon
was going down a full piece i thought
and uh i i don't know i wonder if maybe
the clock was the issue i think on these
lower boards
more than the actual chess position
matters sometimes the clock is just the
deciding factor of these games
but here again peppermint up a full
piece
i left the game last time he was up a
piece because i thought it was over
but leaving the swindler managed to
come back in that game
is this the tournament of the st louis
chess club only um
so this is the corporate chess league
which means it is open
to corporations this year it was
corporations in the st louis area
uh alex in his little intro tonight
hinted at the fact that maybe some
non-local corporations could start to
join
so basically it's a team competition
competition
for corporations right now in the area
so if you are
a part of corporation and oh there's
alex
on the screen um
and yeah we've got some b-roll footage i
didn't realize we had b-roll footage
and we're back i i didn't didn't really
know how to handle that
yeah um okay
uh queen d5 by black but yeah basically
the long and short of it i lost my train
of thought there
but uh the the long and short of it is
yes it is
right now for local st those
corporations it's a team competition
so to enter you would need to find a
team for corporation
uh to participate alex there is the
commissioner
of the corporate chess league so if you
do have a corporation by any chance and
you do want to participate i would
recommend
reaching out to him uh or lauren stewart
i believe their information should be on
our website
for you guys uh let's get back to the
action though
uh we have a result here with josh
whedon
actually resign resigning i think his
name is josh
i just pulled that name out of nowhere i
know his last name is whedon
hopefully his first name is josh but for
unfortunately for him
there was a bit of a tactic that was
missed here with knight e7
uh how else are we doing in the match we
have i think wades has actually
completed his games as well
s sfx is still in progress against oak
ave
and the way i'm looking at it here the
results are are shaping up to be
very very close uh we had whedon
splitting with
peppermint on the bottom board we had
sweet man
going one and a half to a half against
frank tan but dv dutch
going a half to one and a half with kyqz
so
that's a tight score so far i'm not sure
how waves actually ended up i will have
to check that
on my own but it could come down to this
game
between sfx77 it all depends on how
wades did
and how this game goes sfx with the lead
for the moment again
don't trust these chess.com ratings sfx
is much closer to 1400
than he is to 1200 um and yeah
still waiting on nick to put in those
scores probably his game
is still giving him some trouble but
what is going on on the chessboard here
black has more rooks that's what's going
on looks good
for ascension if oak ave is able
to win this game it very much would come
down 100
to that match between wades and s
gilmore 999
if they split their match then it's
gonna be a
tie between worldwide technology and
ascension uh
i know in the events that i've covered
we have had zero ties so that would be a
first for me
don't know if it would be a first for
the season but definitely
that would be something new
something new to be certain all right
i'm going to leave this game i think oak
ave probably has this one in the bag
with an extra rook but why don't we
check in
on another really essential match and
that is the match
between merits
and bayer let's see if any of their
games are still in progress here
and maybe they aren't
ah they do have one there is still the
game between kb3
eua up against vindy here kb
playing for merits and vindy for bayer
and it looks like steve r
has just started uh his second game
against now this is just
losing for bayer so why does this match
matter well merits is
relatively safe with their second place
position right now in the standings
but bayer is just on the cusp of
qualifying
for the playoffs in this grand prix so
if bayer can put up a big score here
against merits
they would leapfrog into qualification
places most likely
and if they do very very well
merits may even be in danger of not
qualifying for those playoffs in
december
so what is going on in this game well kb
with the white pieces
chooses e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6
and a3 so this is the type of move you
want to cut out of your
openings it is not developing a piece
it's not controlling the center and it
does nothing to help castle your king
and those are really the three big
things you look to do
in the opening so since it doesn't do
any of those things
it is just kind of a waste of time there
are just
more efficient ways to spend your time
early in the opening
without playing a3 we see knight f6
black makes use of that time to develop
a piece and pressure the pawn
knight c3 now by white and black
continues using this extra time to break
early early on
in the center d3 bishop g4 h4
and definitely it is white for choice
here
h4 is another very very strange move
would have preferred to see
just some simple development by by white
what companies are playing well edward
jones is currently in the lead
by over 140 points i think close to 150
points
so they have qualified this is the last
leg of the regular season
right now and there are a myriad of
teams trying to qualify
for the post season finals so edward
jones is qualified
enterprise is also competing and they
are i believe right now
in qualification place but they will
need to do well tonight to defend it
merits and bayer is the match we're
looking at right now in both of those
teams
definitely in the contention for
qualifying merits they're in second
place
with a little bit of a cushion but
they're definitely not safe
if bayer upsets them here and takes home
20 points for the match victory
we also have worldwide technology who
we've been following pretty closely
against ascension
ascension in sixth place but only five
points away from a qualification spot
if enterprise were to go down in their
match a win here would be great for
ascension
we also have express scripts who
unfortunately couldn't play tonight
and dougherty with uh 46 points
themselves and they
actually have the buy in this round so
their players are playing sort of the
the overflow games
uh with all that in mind right now it's
coming down
to this last game that did just wrap up
here between oak ave and
sfx 77 so in four of the five matches
i can now confirm that worldwide
technology and ascension have
split the score that means it all comes
down
to weights who i'm going to try to look
up right now
to see how he did because that's going
to be very very
important
if i can actually figure this out bear
with me
all i want to know all i want to know is
how wades did
in his game i'm asking
for a bit too much
maybe i am asking for a bit too much
well we'll have to wait for nick risco
to input the scores here oh and
he's getting around to it now oh my gosh
it looks like wades did actually
go 2-0 against his opponent s gilmore
and with that worldwide technology does
defend their spot
against ascension so with a match
victory there for worldwide technology
they take home
20 full grand prix points which very
much solidifies them
in qualification position and that is a
tough loss for ascension
it's a little bit unclear now if
ascension is going to be able to make up
that gap they needed
before the the end of the night what's
the good news for ascension well the
good news is enterprise also
has lost to edward jones and with that
loss
enterprise is very very much in danger
of losing their their qualification
spot and keeping an eye on
the bayer match against
merits there are still a couple games
left in progress
right now bayer is actually up two
points in that match and it's gonna come
down to these last two games
that we have here if uh merits is able
to win
in both of these games then they will
defend their spot and split the match
but a win on either board for bayer
will make them the victors and with that
they will shoot up with
20 extra points undoubtedly surpassing
enterprise
and potentially even uh
surpassing surpassing merits that they
might surpass merits as well
and we could have a huge shake up in the
standings
let's allow our greats tournament
director nick
to continue updating those scores though
for the moment let's jump back to the
action here
we have kb3 up against vindy this is one
of the last two critical games
in this bayer versus
merits matchup so kb3
is the player for merits here and once
again
bayer the is or vindi is is the player
for bayer
so even a half point on either of these
games
for uh bayer is enough to clinch match
match victory
looks like vindy has a good position
here but let's check in on the other
game
where steve r is playing for merits and
now this is just losing
is the player for bayer the player
for bear so taking a look at this one
here
what is going on on the chessboard
it looks like another interesting
position we're getting a lot of these
closed center types of positions where
one side is dealing with some double
pawns
honestly i think white is doing pretty
well here there are
some tactics being played a discovery on
the night
but i think this may have been a little
bit of a miscalculation there's a knight
takes c6 move
that black is going to have to contend
with here i don't know if
now this is just losing and calculated
this one all the way through
steve's chest.com rating by the way is
almost accurate it looks like his actual
rating is 1216
not just 1200 but you can
sort of trust this rating so we'll see
what steve comes up with here
there's a knight takes c6 move there's
even somehow a knight takes f7 move
that white can consider and i think this
is just going to be a pleasant advantage
for for white if i'm not mistaken
once again bayer needs a half point to
clinch match victory
it looks like steve is really applying
the pressure here if steve takes home
the win
then it's all down to that first game we
looked at
and there is a lot to calculate here for
example there might be even a
third move queen h5 and maybe this is
the best
of the moves that i've looked at here
the point is you apply some pressure to
this f7 pawn
you know to be honest i don't quite
believe in that line just yet
but uh knight takes c6 looks good knight
takes
f7 looks good honestly the simple king
takes h3
and following rick takes e5 with f4 and
b3
that looks very good for white i don't
think white can really go wrong here
with that in mind i think white may be
going wrong here by actually spending so
much time on this decision
as i've said before the clock is a very
relevant factor
any of the main moves look like they're
good to me just play one of them
maintain some time on that clock and
don't go down without a fight okay we
see the interesting queen d7 and this is
now
officially just a sacrifice by black
knight takes b8
attacks the queen you'll have to
recapture and white will be up the
exchange here
what does black have in exchange for it
well black is putting all of his hopes
on the fact that these light squares
are going to be weak for white if black
can occupy these squares
and successfully launch an attack then
black will have some compensation
with that being said though i just don't
buy it
bishop g4 there's one very important
move
that if white plays i think the
advantage is
secured it was not queen e1
although ben feingold says never play f3
f3 is a great great great move in this
position
why is that well whenever you are
missing a bishop that your opponent has
it's oftentimes really really powerful
to make up for that
by attacking those squares with your
pawns so what do i mean
i mean black has a light squared bishop
and white does not that means
black has this great control over all of
the light squares in the position
but blight can actually fight back by
occupying
those lights colored squares with the
pawns for example
f3 g4 and that bishop would be
completely shut out of the game
so that's an important thing to keep in
mind whenever you're missing a bishop
you can compensate for that
by using those pawns to help garda
guard the squares
uh two games left uh according to nick
here
and i imagine those are the two games we
are currently looking at
um this game between steve and now this
is just losing is still in progress i
should say some more moves have been
played and those moves have been very
very bad for steve r
and look at how quickly the tables have
turned
i think white has just checkmated so
queen e1
did not maintain control of those light
squares and then
suddenly out of nowhere steve is getting
checkmated
these light squares did turn out to be
the death of
white's king with black very very
quickly
invading and checkmating and with that
bayer
has in fact clinched this match against
uh
against merits still one game left in
progress though let's take a look over
here
at kb3 how is he shaping up
against vindy as i said earlier every
point matters in this format just
because bayer has clinched the match
doesn't mean kb can relax here because
every point you score
is added to your team's total
and we have yet another position with a
very closed
center the players really seem to be
going for these positions where they
lock the puns in the middle of the board
and try to figure out the complications
and kudos to them
for going for this kind of game because
it is a very complex game it's very easy
to let something slip
in a position like this with so many
pieces left on the board
in such a closed locked up position
so we see g6 now by black and this was
played
because this knight was very much
threatening to come into f5
if i'm white i'm considering the move h5
and kb does go for it just
forcing this pawn out of the way sinking
our knight into the light squares
and we see here that white is firmly in
control
firmly in control i don't really know
how vindy can respond to this you could
go for the maximum amount of tension
with something crazy like f5 but my
heart tells me it's just
not going to be working out for black
here uh
it just looks a little bit too loose to
add this much tension and vindy doesn't
even go for it
goes knight d8 and this is a free pawn
to for white to take now
h6 is going to be weak uh to follow
this knight is still coming to f5 and
this is now
disaster for vindi dang
so if steve had managed to hold on to
that advantage with the rook if he had
played this nice move
f3 i think uh merits would have been
in a good position to defend their their
placement in
the qualifying position but with this uh
bayer
upset here i think that that may be in
danger
merits definitely gonna have to come in
strong in the final
round in order to defend their title and
as i am talking up kb's position there
are some difficulties over here on the
queen's side
and if white isn't careful uh they're
going to get checkmated
how are they going to get checkmated
well let's say they play a natural move
like knight f5
rook takes b3 is actually a nasty nasty
threat
c takes queen takes king a1 is the only
move
then bishop b4 is the knockout punch the
queen moves and
bishops c3 with checkmate and oh boy
are we going to see it will vindy
sacrifice
the rook it takes a lot of guts to play
rook takes b3 and now vindy
okay vindy takes the the calmer approach
the slower approach
vindy is just sinking this bishop on c3
and checkmating
like this and sadly for white that is
also just going to be good enough here
not quite the fireworks that i had
expected
but it is going to be good enough and
wow it says enterprise tied edward jones
i did not realize this
i did not realize this i knew going in
that edward jones has
never lost a head-to-head matchup is
this maybe the first tie
i'm going to have to wait for
confirmation on that but that is a
massive massive result by enterprise
drawing or tying the match with edward
jones how did that happen to be honest
that's a little bit of a crazy one
and yeah it happened due to an excellent
showing on board one by kamikaze knight
for
for enterprise so we didn't get a chance
to really look at that enterprise edward
jones matchup we were more focused
on these four teams all in qualifying
position
but wow enterprise you know they they
showed up when they had to
they were in that fourth place spot just
barely in the qualifying range
and they splitting their match with
edward jones is going to keep them
very much in the running for that
qualification spot
notably by the way alex curford the
wonderful
person you saw during the intro was
unable to play tonight so
perhaps he's having some regret here
that he couldn't show up for his team
try and put up some points himself but
yeah
enterprise huge result massive result
and with that i think we're gonna have
to definitely
keep an eye on their match in round two
uh
when it'll really be for for all the
marbles there
uh kb here by the way is still
considering
trying to look for any way out of this
but sadly
there's there's simply no way to stop
rook a1
checkmate i don't think you can even
survive another move no matter what you
play here can't even check the black
king
can't interfere with this in any way
it's it's just over
it's just over 4kb
and it looks like looks like kb offered
his opponent a draw
uh you know we're worth a shot right
maybe he doesn't see it maybe you have g
takes h8
and uh sadly though vindi did in fact
decline that that draw so
kb here will be going down
but not without a fight not without a
fight had a very good position
bit of a cheeky draw offer there i'd be
lying if i said i had never done it
myself
i'd be lying
um okay while we wait for kb to make his
final move
uh why don't we take a look at the
standings after this round
i believe they should be all up to date
here
so they're kind of up to date right
um they're actually not really totally
up to date probably we're waiting on
this final result before those those
extra match points are added
uh basically merits is in fact
going to only score those two points
assuming vindy sees the checkmate here
and so with that pretty bad result for
them they
are very much in danger of losing their
qualification spot with a win in the
next round though
that could all change and we actually
see ascension
going down against worldwide technology
so
expect those two teams to try to come
back with a little bit more force
in the next round to try to get back
into the qualification range
we also saw uh enterprise splitting
their match with edward jones so despite
the standings only saying they get five
points they will actually be receiving
15 which will likely surpass
merits in the standings and stay well
ahead of ascension
so they should reclaim their fourth
place spot
worldwide technology with their win over
ascension moore
thoroughly secures their spot in
qualification bayer
as well with a solid win will be keeping
their qualification spot as well
uh daugherty for their credit did
reasonably well on those extra boards
and will be receiving um 10 points
for for getting the buy edward jones uh
also
maintains their undefeated record but
does not
maintain their wins only record they
did not win their match against
enterprise only splitting it
and so they receive uh 10 points for
that
in addition to to any board points they
have scored
and yeah to be honest i don't think
those standings are even remotely
correct so maybe nick can take a look at
what is
going on because the board point none of
the math adds up
but it's all up here trust me i know
what's going on
it's all up here and kb by the way down
to 10 seconds
still has not made a move we've got a
show to run buddy let's go
let's go but uh you know
as always it is every chess player's
right to let their clock run out
and it's also their right to resign
whenever they like that's that's
something great about chess
nobody's making you play if you are
tired of looking at your dead position
you can resign at any moment uh
what is this leak well the first round
is now officially over so maybe it is a
good time to refresh everyone's memory
about what we're doing here tonight this
of course is the final leg
of the corporate chess league um the
corporate chess league i believe runs
every quarter
and this quarter we have had some really
exciting action in the grand prix
um yeah and we have an event every month
but i think this grand prix
is only lasting for the quarter no no
it's all six events six events in the
grand finale oh my god all right
the format keeps changing but at its
core this
is uh the the sixth and final event
of the grand prix and the players or the
teams in the top four spots
will be moving on to the finals
in december and right now edward jones
is the only team
that is safe after the first round of
play
we saw beggar doing well enterprise
doing well to maintain that fourth place
spot
worldwide technology doing well and then
the two teams that struggled
merits and ascension they will have to
come back
much much stronger in the second round
in order to qualify
honestly ascension may be close to being
mathematically eliminated
although merits i believe will have a
very good shot with a win in the next
round
of reclaiming qualification it all is
going to come
down to round number two
round number two that's where it's at
and nick is claiming that the standings
are now accurate after the first round
so maybe we can pull that back up as
well
i think these are the mathematically
uh accurate standings now that that nick
has
so doing some quick mental math here uh
edward jones gets
30 points which um
i'm still claiming is is a bit off i
think they should have 25
by my count but i'll leave that to the
professionals
bayer with 28 points which also seems
a bit off i think that should be 26 by
my accounts
um worldwide technology with
26 points let's check next score here
four
uh one two four six and yeah
that one is correct they got 26 points
enterprise
with uh 15 points does seem right they
get 10 match points for splitting with
edward jones and they had five board
points
i know edward jones has extra points
because of those extra boards it all
makes sense how dare i question nick
and then those teams that struggled once
again were ascension
and merits not quite getting the job
done
so a lot to look forward to in round two
let me actually pull
up our pairings here and boy oh boy
they are big pairings
worldwide technology is playing bayer
and
enterprise goes from having probably the
hardest matchup against edward jones to
having a little bit of an
easier time against darty they will be
the heavy heavy heavy favorites
in that second round so honestly if
enterprise wins that round i think they
are in clear to qualify without issue
and worldwide technology up against
bayer is another interesting thing to
look out for
those two teams are in qualification
spot
and then merits against ascension so
merits i don't think it's going to be
enough for them
to just win they have to win big they
have to put up those board points
in order to catch their competitors
worldwide technology
and bayer so let us
see as i think games are actually
getting underway
why don't we pull up some of those games
of enterprise that we didn't take a look
at in the first round
so who is that that is going to be
kamikaze
knight
so let's take a look here we have
kamikaze knight against sweat
sweat board one for dardy with the 1200
chest.com rating
we have him pulled up there we also
are going to be looking at chess hulky
for enterprise
whose game has not yet started
as well as moneyballin for enterprise
so darty can uh actually play a little
bit of spoiler in this event they
are like i said the mass of underdogs uh
and i don't believe
they can qualify for the finals at this
point
but you know they can spoil enterprises
chances enterprise in fourth place there
with a few key wins doherty could knock
them out of the running
that being said sweyak is not off to
the most principled start of all time
there are three goals in the opening you
want to
control the center you want to develop
your pieces
and you want to castle your king f6
not achieving those goals and it's also
a very very weakening move
on this diagonal this pawn on f7 closes
that diagonal and
oh my god oh my god say it ain't so
bishop takes knight pawn takes that's
that's
checkmate oh boy oh boy oh not a good
start
for sweyak unfortunately there uh and i
believe
that may be the fastest point we've ever
seen
in the history of the corporate chess
league that one did not take long
tough game for sweat don't play f6 you
weaken this diagonal and then g5
is just fatal six move checkmate there
okay let's check in on moneyballin
against eight he hayes here we have atas
for darny against moneyballin and
this game seems off seems to be off to a
little bit of a better start
how can you go about entering your
company info into a future
competition maybe ben can pull up a link
for you we do have that information
available on our website i believe the
ticket is to contact lauren stewart who
is in charge of these things
and her email should be listed on our
website stluischestclub.org
look for the corporate chess league look
for lauren and then you'll be good to go
um with that in mind though this game in
progress
we have a bit of an interesting one here
where again
black is going for this d6 e5 setup we
are seeing this
a lot these days and in this case it's
getting an early knight on d4
now this idea i think makes sense if
white already has a pawn committed to
the e4 square as well
but here if i'm white i would have
really considered just playing pawn e3
making this knight move again and then
developing out to attack this guy again
the more times i can make my opponent
move this night the happier i
am we see bishop e3 in the game though
and now c5 to support the knight and d
takes c
on passant to remove that defender and
now after c
takes i think white is in fact just able
to win a pawn here on the d4
square again another case of a situation
where black needed to get a little bit
more developed
in order in order for these ideas to to
work
just a little bit too cavalier in the
opening
with these early night moves
okay who else do we have we have chess
hulky whose game should be getting
underway
rather shortly
or maybe not
yeah don't see chess hulky's game so i
think it's time we leave this enterprise
match
with that early uh point uh
by kamikaze night i think they are just
in very good position
to win the match so where does that
leave us i think the key matchup here
is going to be merits against ascension
um worldwide technology and bayer it
would be very very nice
for them to win in fact you know now
that i'm thinking about the standings i
think it's essential
for worldwide technology or bayer to win
i think the loser of that match
may be dethroned by the winner of merits
ascension so
everything on the line here in the final
round
so who do we want to watch well i don't
think we have seen anything by maybe
swap so let's take a look at that game
maybe swap maybe swap has the black
pieces against kyqz
a familiar name at this point kyqz did
manage to put up
an impressive score against dv dutch
board one
for worldwide technology let's see how
he does
against maybe swap here board one for
merits
and again don't be fooled by the
chess.com rating maybe swap is in 1870
a far cry from the 1642 rating that you
see on your screen here
that being said kyqz is still the
favorite with that 1900 rating
and what exactly is happening here
okay it's another interesting position
we get
yet again a closed center these
positions are starting to like hurt my
eyes to look at there's just too many
pawns on the board
but white has an excellent outpost on
the f5 square
we saw white actually push this h pawn
up to h5
just making things a little bit more
frightening around the black king's side
but the story is sort of the reverse
over here on the queen side this is a
powerful knight for the moment
on c4 and black has good control over
the open queen side files
what does that mean well it's going to
be a contest to see who wins first
either black is going to win on the
queen side taking advantage of the weak
a pawn
or white is going to win on the king's
side just checkmating the black king
it is a bit of a race here knight b2 is
a bit of a weird move by maybe swap
but i can't you know directly refute it
and white's not even interested
in trying to trap this knight uh kyqz is
going
for the throat here going for checkmate
and it's a very risky idea for the
moment this is the sacrifice of the apon
if black is willing to take it
i don't believe white actually has a
tangible threat on the king's side it
looks scary with these three pieces
lining up
but i i just don't see the threat i just
don't
see the knockout punch so black takes
this pawn
has an extra c pawn and probably now the
plan for black is to push this guy
forward
and hope to god you don't get checkmated
that is the plan push the pawn and hope
and kyqz is left with that dot
all right let's take a look at board two
in this matchup
between i am rounder and frank
tan while that game is still in progress
and thank god it's not a closed center
they traded some central pawns
finally i can breathe a little bit
easier and
unfortunately for frank tan this one is
looking
scary those bishops are powerful
powerful pieces
bearing down on this king's side is
there immediately a forced
checkmate i think queen h5 is probably
the way to go here if g6 then queen h6
is making some awkward threats and if
anything else
then rook g4 and dual threats on the
king
maybe even rook g4 immediately there are
a lot of options you can go rook d4
first if you want to be especially mean
about it
i think white is as close to to winning
in this position
close to winning here okay we do see
queen h5 first and i think this is
you know along the right track if g6
queen h6
and the question uh i guess is maybe
white black can play the move f6 i have
some very serious doubts i think rook g4
followed by bishop takes g6 and that's
going to be the end of the game
we'll see if i am rounder can come up
with it we'll see if frank tan can come
up with
any clever defense that i'm just not
seeing but i think white here
is doing quite well off to a good start
then
for merits against ascension
uh with that in mind though i think
merits is a little bit
top heavy with their roster i think they
do well on boards one and two
but boards three and four i think they
are a bit of the underdogs so they
need to be putting up points on those
top two boards because ascension
is actually favored in every match up
here
yeah ascension is the favorite in every
matchup so merits
an underdog to maintain their
qualification spot we'll see if they can
pull it off here
with that in mind let's take a look at
board
three of this match
and that is going to be between steve r
19
and s gilmore
if i can pull it up
and let's look from s gilmer's point of
view i don't think we've seen too much
of him yet today
we did see steve uh playing a bit in the
last round
so what is going on here what is the
plan
in this position well we see white with
the wide open g file definitely i think
this is going to be
white for choice once again i did a
quick pawn count
white has an extra pawn and this king is
looking a little bit toasted a little
bit toasted gonna have to move the king
off of the g
file here to break the pin and yeah we
don't see black do that
definitely bishop takes pawn here is
along the right track maybe black is
claiming that queen takes b2 is just
like worth it
you just go queen takes b2 who cares if
you're trying to checkmate me
i'm taking your pawn and taking either
your rook or your knight
it's an interesting idea it's the right
uh i think it's the right thinking here
for black you just sort of go for broke
try and shake things up and make
something interesting happen
so we'll see if it works and yeah
gilmore
having none of it just goes b4 defends
the pawn
he knows the threats on the king's side
aren't going away may as well
stop all the counter play first
and with that that brings us to board
4 the final board of this merits
ascension
match up which is again going to be kb3
against oak ave
so let's pull up oak ave here if we can
and wow this game has progressed this
game has progressed
looks like white has an extra rook and a
myriad of extra pawns
should be good for oak ave so sort of
as expected ascension is starting to
clean up on those lower boards which
means
they're going to need an outrageous
performance on those top two boards iam
rounder has to get it done against frank
tan
and maybe swap has to get it done
against kyqz it's it's not going to be
easy
by any means but merits isn't out of it
just yet
let's check back in on that board one
game here where maybe swap
was looking good early on and is this a
checkmating attack who's getting
checkmated here i can't really tell
if king age one oh king h1 this was mate
that was made in one
matin one was missed i thought rook f2
had to be played then this check
and queen takes but then counter play
over here
it was looking very complicated but mate
in one
missed for black you hate to see it and
that being said maybe swap should still
be winning this game
he's up two pieces for the moment and
should still have a checkmating attack
but
would have been nice to just play mate
in one and get it over with because
anything can happen in these games under
five minutes
right this is anyone's game
well it's not exactly anyone's game
definitely maybe swap is heavily heavily
favored
but anything can happen is what i'm
trying to say
so what's the best checkmate here what's
the best mate probably we give check
kink here and queen e3 looks pretty good
queen e3 rook f2 queen e1 rook f1
rick h1 king h1 queen one king h2
yeah i'm not seeing the checkmate but we
go knight g4 there and win the queen
so i found a win we'll see if maybe swap
finds a different win
the thing i don't think you should get
baited into is playing this move queen
h2
oftentimes queen h2 is mate but this
time it's just not
so queen h2 not checkmate and i think
now
uh white black may have a slightly more
difficult time
finding their way through to to the win
that being said king e2 queen g2 clearly
wins king e1 queen
h4 queen g3 queen g3 is probably just
clearly winning
and shouldn't be too too difficult here
for maybe swap
and if all these games end the way i'm
expecting them to at this point
i i think it's going to be a split score
between um
merits and ascension after the first
game in this round
and that it's just shaping up for an
even more exciting
final game i believe the winner of this
match should be in good position to
qualify
assuming that uh worldwide technology
and bayer don't split the match i think
if
worldwide technology bears somehow draw
their match
then perhaps it doesn't matter if
ascension wins i don't think ascension
could catch up
remains to be seen though that is a
victory for maybe swap let's check back
in on im rounder
we saw that pressure on the king's side
and it has now
you know amounted to some sort of attack
is it enough
looks like rook g6 should be played here
it looks a little bit complex
but it should be a good move and
after queen f7 god i don't know
it's too complicated i don't like this
move e5 now black is starting to fight
back
black is is getting back into it here
frank tan clawing his way back into this
game
e5 i think this has to be played and it
is played
now what do you do with this queen it's
so difficult to keep up the pressure
that's the issue with these these types
of attacks where
optically they look very good but if you
make a few
inaccurate moves your opponent is right
back in the game
right back in the game so queen c4 check
and where will black uh go i think you
do have some problems if you try to
block for example with queen e6 you're
one running into queen takes and bishop
c4
with yet another pin when that would
pick up material
khada i think looks fine but we do see
queen e6 and this is a blunder
this is a blunder queen trade bishop c4
and that is some extra material
for im rounder what is the tournament
called it's called the corporate chess
league
that's what it's called yeah bishop c4
and i am render has
found it you can even go rook g6 try and
build up the pressure here but just
bishop takes c4 or e6 keeping it simple
rook g7 now and this is a winning
advantage for white
this h pawn is very very dangerous and
it's going to be difficult for frank to
you know you can only come back from the
dead so many times
um i've heard this term a lot in
a board game called go less so in chess
but i think it really does apply here
that they were it was looking like this
game was going to be what's known as a
zombie game
black was dead but they came back from
the dead
to to make it interesting but it looks
like in this case
the zombie has been vanquished as i am
rounder
is still going to be winning in the end
game
not quite the middle game checkmate that
it once looked like
but a winning end game is worth exactly
the same number of points
as a checkmate in the middle game
okay and yeah now i am rounder just
going to push these pawns up the board
i'm happy to leave this game uh i will
you know add the the short little
disclaimer here that as long as the
knight is on the board you can never be
absolutely certain of anything
those things will always be able to fork
king and rook
uh whenever possible but for the moment
looking good
by the way checking in on oak ave they
did win their first game against kb
so for the moment we do have a level
score
against in in this match between merits
and ascension
checking back in maybe swap is well
underway against kyq
q z and we saw that
steve was in a lot of trouble against
gilmore and yeah that that has
shaped up the way we expected it to with
gilmore now up an extra queen and even
more importantly up a minute and 40
seconds
this this game is over uh let's see if
uh im rounder can put the finishing
touches on this one though
uh running a bit low on the clock but
nothing too crazy
yeah king f6 rick f7 now picks up the
knight and with that
all hopes of surviving this game are
fairly
lost um
so after one round it's it well after
the first game in the round it's going
to be totally level
between merits and ascension and this is
absolutely critical
everything is going to come down to
round two to see who is qualifying
for the big old finals
um okay with that why don't we check in
on worldwide technology against bayer
because the winner of that match is
definitely qualifying for the finals
so let's take a look at essentia i don't
think we've seen
their game yet and i was unable to
follow them maybe they're done
yeah maybe their games are actually
already over on the top board
so we won't see what happened there
let's also follow
sweet man here see how sweet man is
doing
we have gilmore starting their second
game by the way
click out of that for the moment we do
have sweet man against eagle eye here
and it's down to the wire sweet man
definitely in control for the moment
with those two
central past pawns and an extra two
minutes on the clock i think the two
minutes are even more important than the
past pawns in this case
eagle-eye gonna have to move extremely
extremely quickly to stay in this game
and it's just too complicated to make
those quick moves
that being said he's found a plan right
he's he's got a plan and he's sticking
to it
white with a similar plan but whose pawn
will be faster
i wonder i wonder
not quite a wonder but i do wonder
looks like it's good for white i think
this move rook f7 is gonna be sealing
the deal here
uh rook f7 takes takes is almost forced
and then
this king has to go to h8 e7
and that is going to be checkmate
shortly um and even better than
checkmate winning on time
so sweetman takes an early lead in the
match for worldwide technology
let's check in now on wades as well
see if we can get wade's game up here
i'm gonna click out of this one for the
moment we do have wades against now this
is just losing and wades also has
already won
the first game against now this is just
losing
and while that looks like a bit of an
upset by these ratings wades is actually
a 1500 not a 1000 so not too too
surprising there
and then what's going on on board four
we have sfx
77 on board four let's see how they are
doing
as well sfx up against
vindy here and wow sfx has also won
his first game so that is a three
nothing lead
for worldwide technology over bayer
that is a massive lead to start out with
and depending on how those board one
games were going
i think worldwide technology is in very
very good
position to qualify for those finals
that being said the merits ascension
match is still close so why don't we
check back in there
let's check back in on maybe swap on
board
one of this match it was a upset
win for maybe swap in the first game and
we'll see if he can pull it off again
although wow that's a lot of pieces
hanging all of a sudden
okay all right we came into some tactics
here
it looks like material is even but the c
pawn does seem like it's a bit more
useful than the f pawn for the moment
we'll see if that remains true
rookie 2 was played and i really don't
like this trade by black to be honest i
think knight c4 would have been awkward
to deal with there
a very powerful knight instead though
the knight disappears from the board
and so do white's worries you no longer
have to be concerned
with this knight hitting this dark
squared bishop and life is good
why is this dark squared bishop so
important well as i've said before
white is missing the light squared
bishop and so is trying to control those
squares with these pawns and that means
that this bishop
is all the more important to guard all
these empty dark squares
in position without this bishop white is
sort of dead
so you need this bishop on the board to
keep everything together and that knight
could have made it very very awkward to
deal with
uh in the meantime we see rook f to d8
as always chess is a game of give and
take you are
getting the d file but you are giving up
some control over this f7 pawn so be on
the lookout for any potential tactics
arriving on that square as well
what moves am i considering if i maybe
swap well maybe
i swap the rooks off with rook takes d8
and rook d1
i think the huge benefit to actually
having this f
pawn is it does make the black king a
bit safer than the white king
which is why i'm happy to start trading
off some major pieces here if i can get
rid of the major pieces
i know i'm not going to get checkmated
and this c pawn starts to go
up in value why well this c pawn is
passed and the f pawn is
not it's all about recognizing the
imbalance in this case
c pawn for f pawn and making that
imbalance work for you
in this case an end game is where that
imbalance works for white and that's
what he should be going for
bishop c6 is a nice move by kyqz putting
suppression now
on this pawn there is a bishop b6 move
but i don't think it wins anything
either queen b7 or rook b8
and there's a pin on the b file bishop
could not move
due to the queen hanging and so what
will maybe swap come up with here
what's the idea
essentia i'm being told never showed up
so that could be a 2.4 foot win for
worldwide technology
which actually would clinch the match
for them after one game
that would clinch the match because the
lower three boards
won every game so if essentia
truly did not show up as nick is telling
me then
worldwide technology will have qualified
by force
is there a rating cap there is no rating
cap i will say though
that the chess.com ratings are often
inaccurate uh maybe swap is closer to
1870 than 1640. i think a lot of these
players just don't play on chess.com
which is why you're seeing
some really crazy differentials there
okay rook b8 played in the game uh
bishop f2 was a nice move by white just
keeping things solid keeping this pawn
defended
but again i would feel better if none of
these major pieces were on the board
right here i think white can go b4 and
keep control a little bit
just keep this pawn defended and you
really want to start pushing this guy up
the board this pawn is your advantage
you need it in the game
um and with that in mind i did just hang
my e pawn
which apparently both me and maybe swap
probably missed
because queen b7 was actually a dual
threat so looking a bit awkward now
looking a bit awkward now for white
though that light squared bishop did
turn out to be
really really powerful maybe i
underestimated black's position a little
bit or maybe it was just handled
very well knight g5 i think is good
although it does hang the cheap on as
well yeah okay maybe maybe it wasn't so
good
bishop f1 now is an interesting tactic
threatening checkmate and the rook rook
e4 would have to be played
it's just starting to look a bit awkward
looking a bit awkward for maybe swap and
that's a huge win
for kyqz that is a massive win for
ascension
they must do well on these upper
upper boards well actually
i say that they don't even have to do
that well they're favored in every
match-up it was
a nice showing by merits in that first
round to keep the score level
but now perhaps the rating advantage is
starting to make itself known here
with ascension winning on this top board
let's check in on board number two
as well looks good for ascension and
kyqz there
and wow board two i am rounder is the
the star of the show here for merits it
looks like
an extra queen for a rook is a winning
advantage here for im rounder against
frank tan
tough matchup for frank in this case
with that in mind there's two more games
in this matchup
let me pull up the game
of gilmore against steve r
with 19 in his name forgot the number
and yeah steve had a tough go of it
against gilmore in
the first round but looking to fight
back here and we have
sort of a a very strange looking
position once again
this knight on a2 is probably the reason
why white is unhappy
if this knight were somewhere like
g3 e4 f5 already then
white might enjoy a slight advantage
thanks to this powerful piece on c4
but with this knight on a2 there's
absolutely nobody on the planet who's
going to claim that white is better here
right you just need this knight back in
the game it's going to take a little bit
too long
to play these four moves black is
looking to play actively
with that in mind though if black
doesn't do something constructive
in the next four moves then i do think
white is going to have the edge
if this knight can get back into the
game rook g8 was hinting at some ideas
of playing g5 and so we see steve
go clean g5 trying to prevent that idea
putting some lateral pressure on the c
pawn as well
and yeah this one is shaping up to be an
interesting game here
shaping up to be an interesting game
what else do we have well we have kb
against oak ave on the lowest board here
oak ave
playing for ascension kb playing for
merits and this one i think is the
biggest mismatch
of the uh of the pairing
oak ave is by far higher rated than kb
we saw kb being a little bit of a
uh a little bit of a jokester in the
last round
playing on when there's mate and one on
the board uh and
letting his clock run out and we'll see
what happens here against
oak ave right now what is going on
well what's going on is white has an
extra piece right
white has two knights and a bishop
against two bishops
with that being said though i think
black is probably
just winning this position uh for one
there is
always a huge problem when you develop a
bishop outside the pawn chain normally
it's more active outside the pawn chain
but if you actually take away both
retreating diagonals for the bishop
the bishop is very very likely to get
trapped and in this case
the move d5 would just be trapping this
bishop and reclaiming
that piece for black in addition to that
you do see this pressure on the king
over here and
this knight is totally out of play for
the moment not really contributing
to the defense and not really helping
out here on the queen side too much
if i'm black i'm just gonna play d5 and
take this bishop back once i have my
piece back there's no reason why white
should still be in the game
so looks good for oak ave and ascension
here on the lowest board
it's a tough fight on board three frank
tan in trouble and
kyqz doing well against maybe swap so
let's jump back to this game
uh and my oh my oh my what has happened
here
white for the moment has an extra
exchange
but we see kyqz playing for checkmate
playing for some tactics as well i think
this one is actually just winning for
uh for black here the only way to keep
the exchange would be to play
rook g2 but that immediately loses to
either queen h1
or queen f3 when the queen and the
bishop start working together
and uh this rook is going to fall i
guess queen h1 is a bit better
forcing king e2 and then this guy falls
and
this guy falls as well that's why you
see king e2 immediately by maybe swap
not trying to keep the rook but now uh
kyqz chooses the simple option
of just trading into a winning endgame
it's not even an endgame i'm sorry you
can't recapture this because of queen h2
so
even simpler than that um kyqz is just
uh
just going up a full piece here uh in a
position where kyqz is already up
many many pawns queen f3
and yeah a very accurate finish by ky
king f1
bishop e3 now and that is the match
maybe swap goes down
against kyqz after a tough fight so that
levels their score up there let's say
that frank uh does go down when i am
rounder has the extra queen
that would keep the score level uh
as well ascension with the one point
lead i should say with the win by kyqz
that means i am rounder will have to win
on board two to level the score
as we expect him to do with an extra
queen and that brings it down
to the lower two boards we have
steve r fighting against s gilmore and i
think steve is gonna need to score a
full
point in order to tie the match uh i say
tie the match
because i do think that this position is
good
for black although as i say that things
are rapidly developing here maybe i
counted kb
out a bit too quickly this knight that
was once so
forlorn on the a4 square has suddenly
and mysteriously made its way to the d3
square
which is a lot a lot better
we might see the queens come off the
board and then this extra piece is going
to start to be felt
for whites i wonder what actually
happened in this game because
at this exact moment i was saying d5 in
black is winning
b5 was played instead and i just do not
support this move it brought this knight
back to life
by force taking on c4 gives this knight
a great square
and black is i think just doing well now
just doing what what is this
rook takes bishop rook takes bishop
oh white had no time i didn't realize
should have looked at the clock i i
always say the clock's the most
important thing but i didn't even look
at the clock
so rook takes bishop and okav wins on
time so that puts
actually merits in a must-win situation
they trail
by two points in the match we expect iam
rounder to be able to convert this
although he
also is low on the clock with the extra
queen
and that leaves all the pressure on
steve
steve with a very reasonable position
this knight still just
stranded on a2 i want this piece to live
i want it back in the game but it's so
so tough
black now by the way makes the threat of
rook takes h3
steve notices and plays f3 to stunt the
diagonal
the threat by the way was rook takes
pawn takes
uh if arrows are so hard on this website
and then queen h1 which would actually
be checkmate supported by the bishop
f3 was played maybe knight takes a5 was
a consideration as well i think this
move probably was a bit better but f3
keeping it solid and it's once again
going to be a story of
the clock here gilmore down to a minute
and 20 seconds
by the way this is a 10 minute game
there's no increment
gilmore is never getting any of that
time back so it's going to be a tall
order to checkmate steve r
in the remaining minute and 18 seconds
and with that we could see a very
important tie
in the match between merits and
ascension merits i think has a bit more
points
than ascension currently so i think they
would be the ones that could potentially
qualify
with a tie here but it's it's all up in
the air to be honest it is
all up in the air nobody knows what's
going to happen
queen g7 is a bold bold bold move
by steve r if i'm playing white here i
look at the clock
i see a minute and 12 seconds i say okay
let me play simple solid chess
i'll bring my knight back into the game
so i can play with both of my pieces
i'll keep my king safe and i'll win on
time queen takes g7 is taking a pawn
but ripping open a file directly in
front of the white king
and that's a little bit scary right and
as the clocks run
down if black finds a random checkmate
out of nowhere
then the game ends it doesn't matter the
black slow on time if i'm in checkmate
so
not a huge fan of queen takes g7 from a
practical perspective
it may have just been the best move but
it's tough
tough to actually play that move by the
way let's flip back to i
am rounder who is down to 30 seconds 30
seconds on the clock queen b3 would have
been a great winning move
but yet you know i was calling this game
early with the extra queen
but i am rounder oh it's they're so slow
you got to go faster
23 seconds and i'm sort of losing it
here
i'm sort of losing it i i think frank is
is gonna somehow pull it out
frank has been down a queen since early
on in the game
but with some tenacious play the game is
not
over the game is not over 20 seconds
i think frank is favored at this point
if you ask me
15. you have to move play a move
queen c1 alright they found queen c1 you
can't take this pawn because of queen c2
check
queen c2 check oh queen b2 it's
oh my goodness oh the drama
i think frank is gonna clinch it here
for his team it's just too hard to play
this end game with seven seconds left
queen c2 was the only hope
taking that rook off the board but now
it's it's over queen b8
queen b8 okay queen b8 was found but
i i worry it's too little too late
you take the rook but 2.2 seconds left
it's
it's going to be the match here it's
going to be the match
yeah and white wins by timeout
a brutal brutal finish for meretz's
chances
and yeah steve's game now unfortunately
will not make the difference
even if he does manage to hold on in
this position
it will not matter ascension has
defeated merits
with that flag by frank frank the
flagger
not them dead and with that
it's going to be a very close uh fight
between
bayer and ascension actually i think
this game may still matter if gilmore
does not if gilmer wins this game
he scores an extra board point for
ascension
and i think it's those board points that
are making the difference right now
between
bayer and ascension i think bayer has
lost their match against worldwide
technology but if there aren't enough
board points
then aren't enough board points by
ascension
i think bayer still qualifies so it'll
be interesting to see how the scores
actually shake out
uh we do see though gilmore is going
down here there were some tactics
that were a bit silly by the way i think
the last few moves didn't make the most
sense
um knight takes here probably black
should be taking the queen
and then after takes queen e2 there is
actually still a fork available to black
but you know time pressure these things
get missed and now white with the extra
queen
still hasn't fixed this knight on a2 i'm
not calling this a piece
but the extra queen is is going to be
good enough here again
check queen c7 and checkmate is
unstoppable on b7 or a7
30 seconds to find it and he does
and he does
so good showing by steve here good
showing by merits on the whole
but i do think this knocks them out of
qualification
um unless there's some funny business
with
with those final scores i don't know
we're going to have to see how it shakes
out because
i only know one thing i know it's going
to be close it's going to be close
between
actually all three teams uh merits
ascension and bayer depending on how
those final scores look
i i do not know who is actually
qualifying what i do know
is edward jones is qualified and i
believe actually
worldwide technology has secured their
qualification by winning that match
against bayer let me close out of some
games here
and let us take a look at
some of these worldwide technology games
sweet man
still in progress nope sweet man is done
for the day
how is wade's doing wade's is done for
the day as well
and okay i think probably all of those
games are actually
completed i'm willing to bet enterprise
has
finished most of their games as well are
there actually any games left
i wonder i don't think they are playing
knock on wood we might be out of games
oh no
yeah no king taker is playing yet is
this it
are we done
i think we might be done ah we there's a
game we've got a game left
let me just finish going down the list
here
see if anybody else is left
all right we have 10 john who i believe
is playing for edward jones
up against ah someone random i think
this is just a game in the random pool i
think dn
finished his game against jarazelski and
is now
just playing a random person on
chess.com but
you know what he's competing in the
corporate chess league so it counts
all games are done and standings are up
to date well why don't we take a look at
those standings then
uh it looks like these are the final
scores
for the day worldwide technology and
enterprise were both in qualification
spot
going into today and they have secured
that
with an enterprise's case a draw in the
first round and a win
in the second and in worldwide
technologies
case actually just two wins for the day
they
swept their opponents and wow actually i
should mention
worldwide technology won every single
game against bayer
that is an impressive showing ascension
just barely barely barely defeated
uh merits in that last round there
by a single point and they did it
with a nice flag win by frank tan down
a queen for a rook for most of the game
but holding on and putting the pressure
on that clock and eventually coming home
with the victory
so it's going to be tight it's going to
be really really close
to see who qualifies here donnie with 11
points on the night and merits
only with five they lost both of their
matches
and they do have a pretty small team
roster so notably
they were a points away from scoring 16
points
but instead they they only get the five
tough night
for merits who is in second place going
into tonight we'll see if they did
enough
to stay in the qualification
and then the game of the night and if
they stayed all right we'll see
if they stayed in the qualification zone
i think we are going to take a very
quick break and then we'll be back with
those final grand prix scores
we're gonna find out who actually
qualified for those finals in december
and uh we'll get back to you with that
information as well as
a game of the nights my favorite game of
the night we shall see
see you guys soon
my name is alex curford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones and
team captain of our trevor jones chess
team
the corporate chess league is an
opportunity
for companies around the st louis area
and hopefully one day beyond
to come and compete at a world-class
facility of
chess that we have here in st louis and
we decided to
get a tournament around that to where
companies can play one another
compete in a friendly a competitive way
and enjoy each other's company as well
chess is important for
a wide variety of people because it
helps with your decision making
it will help with your problem solving
being able to think long term
and have short-term intermediate steps
can
translate into all types of different
areas of life
ever jones chose to compete in the
corporate chess league
as a way that we can
have some fun camaraderie with other
companies that we're associated with
as well as a way to for ourselves be
able to
build some some teamwork aspects as we
have as a company
and again just be able to come and
participate at a top class facility and
have some fun
the st louis chess club world chess hall
of fame and legendary world chess
champion gary kasparov
invite you to attend strategy across the
board the virtual
fourth annual gala a fundraiser to
advance st louis
through the artistic cultural and
educational value of chess
strategy across the board will be held
online tuesday december 1st
from 6 30 to 8 pm central standard time
come celebrate with us reserve your
virtual ticket now
my name is alex curford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones
and team captain of our timber jones
test team
the corporate chess league is an
opportunity
for companies around the st louis area
and hopefully one day beyond
to come and compete at a world-class
facility
of chess that we have here in st louis
and
we decided to get a tournament around
that to where
companies can play one another compete
in a friendly
a competitive way and enjoy each other's
company as well
chess is important for a wide variety of
people
because it helps with your decision
making it will help with your problem
solving
being able to think long term and have
short-term intermediate steps can
translate into
all types of different areas of life
ever jones chose to compete in the
corporate chess league
as a way that we can
have some fun camaraderie with other
companies that we're associated with
as well as a way to for ourselves be
able to
build some some teamwork aspects as we
have as a company
and again just be able to come and
participate at a top class facility and
have some fun
the st louis chess club world chess hall
of fame and legendary world chess
champion gary kasparov
invite you to attend strategy across the
board the virtual
fourth annual gala a fundraiser to
advance st louis
through the artistic cultural and
educational value of chess
strategy across the board will be held
online tuesday december 1st
from 6 30 to 8 pm central standard time
come celebrate with us reserve your
virtual ticket now
my name is alex kirford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones and team captain
of our deborah jones test team
the corporate chesley is an opportunity
for companies around the st louis area
and hopefully one day beyond
to come and compete at a world-class
facility
of chess that we have here in st louis
and
we decided to get a tournament around
that to where
companies can play one another compete
in a friendly
a competitive way and enjoy each other's
company as well
chess is important for a wide variety of
people
because it helps with your decision
making it will help with your problem
solving
being able to think long term and have
short-term intermediate steps can
translate into all types of different
areas of life
ever jones chose to compete in the
corporate chess league
as a way that we can
have some fun camaraderie with other
companies that we're associated with
as well as a way to for ourselves be
able to
build some some teamwork
all right everyone the math is done
we have the official results ready for
you first and foremost though before
you know we do the drum roll and release
the final standings
i would like to announce the best game
of the event
at least in my opinion um i believe
there is
a prize for this last month the prize
was a lesson with me
which went unclaimed so i i'm looking at
you prize winner if you want your prize
i will be offended so reach out to
lauren please
i am rounder is the winner of the best
game prize
for his game number one against frank
tan of ascension uh it was a great
attacking back and forth game
had me on the edge of my seat and i am
rounder did end up
on top at the end of the game so
congratulations to him
and then perhaps more importantly the
final
standings for the teams edward jones as
expected is qualifying easily
extending their lead over second place
to over 150 points
worldwide technology had a very good
night winning both their matches now
in clear second place qualifies for the
finals in december
enterprise also holding their own
standing up
to the big bullies at edward jones who
think they are just gonna win
every match easily they drew that match
with edward jones and secured
their third place spot to qualify and
then here it is
right here that fourth place spot it was
a close
one bayer by just three and a half
points
is qualifying for the finals ascension
despite a strong showing against merits
they needed a blowout against merits to
qualify
and they did not get enough board points
so sadly
they will have to try their luck again
in january
merits as well just barely losing that
final match to ascension
also lost their chance of qualifying and
going into tonight
merits was looking good they were in
second place but that just goes to show
anything can happen here express skips
scripts uh did not play tonight and they
ended on 92 and a half points
and darty uh ends up on 57 points
as well which 57 is a lot of points
that's nothing there's nothing wrong
with that as well
um alright everyone i would like to
thank all of the teams and all the
players in this competition
as always i had a great time bringing
you the live
coverage of it uh we hope to see you all
back
in december and we hope to see even more
of you
here in january coming up for the next
edition of the corporate chess league as
alex said
this is something that's growing it's
expanding it's fun it's exciting
uh i think this is
quickly becoming one of my favorite
events to cover
and it's one of our favorite events to
to organize so
hopefully you guys enjoy it as well
please let me know if you did
once again i am rounder claim your prize
okay
reach out to lauren and she'll get you
set up with with everything
and that's gonna do it for our show here
tonight so once again
thank you guys for watching my name is
caleb denby and i will see you
next time
the st louis chess club world chess hall
of fame and legendary world chess
champion gary kasparov invite you to
attend strategy across the board
the virtual fourth annual gala a
fundraiser to advance st
louis through the artistic cultural and
educational value of chess
strategy across the board will be held
online tuesday december 1st
from 6 30 to 8 pm central standard time
come celebrate with us reserve your
virtual ticket now
you